[Music]
hello and welcome to the active
inference lab this is actin flab live
stream number 32.1321
stochastic chaos and markov blankets
welcome to the active inference lab
we are a participatory online lab that
is learning
communicating
and practicing applied active inference
you can find us at some of the links
here on this slide
this is a recorded and an archived live
stream so please provide us with
feedback so that we can improve on our
work
all backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome here and we'll be following good
video etiquette for live streams
at this short link you can see some of
the past present and upcoming live
streams we are here in the early
november 2021
32 discussions
on stochastic chaos and markov blankets
and in the second half of november we'll
be talking about the paper thinking like
a state and we haven't yet set the
papers for 34 and 35 so if you have any
ideas or if you're an author you want to
come on to discuss
for these states
then get in touch with us
today in active stream 32.1 the goal is
to learn and discuss this extremely
interesting paper stochastic chaos and
markov blankets by fristen heinz oltofer
decosta and par from 2021
and there's a lot to cover in this paper
there's a lot of formalisms and figures
and keywords and
broader questions so i'm sure we'll have
a lot to think about and discuss
if you're watching live then please feel
free to write a question in the chat
because otherwise stephen and i are just
chilling here
so
let's get into it um with uh just intros
and warm-ups and if others join we'll
have them introduce themselves when they
do join but for now let's just um say
hello and maybe bring up just um
something that excited us about coming
to this discussion or something that we
wanted to resolve today
so
i'm daniel i'm a researcher in
california and something that i liked or
remembered about the paper was that
there was
seemingly some changes
or updates to the formalism
of core terms
and so how to understand that in the
broader trajectory of the literature
which one of these changes are like
updates where is it a software update
where is it a breaking change and then
what are the implications of those
changes for some of the broader
conclusions that people do or want to
draw from active inference and the fep
like the nature of thingness or
biological systems or levels of nested
organization
so stephen
yes uh good morning from toronto um i'm
stephen i'm
um i'm doing a practice based phd which
is kind of moves into a methods based
phd
i work a lot with
group processes and working with spatial
creative spatial approaches
to help do sense making
so i'm really interested in active
inference within that as a as a kind of
unifying way to help to
close a lot of the loops and the
fragmented
uh questions that come up when trying to
do sense making with different types of
people in different types of spaces so
um
yeah and as with daniel i'm really
interested about this paper
um as
after the initial
view of it because you see stochastic
chaos and
i'm consciously trying to not go too far
down
sort of an abstract academic aspect of
things
um
but i realized that actually these
underlying processes have got quite a
lot of applications
in this ability to understand why and
how things are unifying um
and i think that's really exciting um
because there's a lot of sort of
semi-markovian
like looks at larger cognitive processes
there's certain
practices and inactivist processes
um but what we tend to see when it gets
down into the nitty-gritty is it's it's
how
are things bubbling up through um the
kind of stochastic
chaos of of the world and life um
or should i just say stochastic
separated chaotic
processes and so the idea of having
stochastic chaos and what that means and
this paper does that
is quite useful to
start to look at what it means to have
to be able to reconcile those approaches
so
it actually does start to help think
about more applied approaches so that's
something i'm i'm interested and excited
about this paper
thank you stephen
in the
32.0
this is kind of
the lead-in was this topic of flow
and that is in a way what might start to
bridge this distinction that you raised
and will definitely return to between
kind of abstractions and applications
flow is a term that has
applications across domains from the
flow of water flow of people flow of
information and money to psychological
flow it's kind of a nomadic term it's a
transdisciplinary term
and then
that's an abstraction we're abstracting
to the patterns of flow
that help us connect the dots across
these different systems but also we want
to apply it we don't just want to say
well waters flow and information is flow
and that's the end of the story
so
how abstractions and applications
kind of work like the left and the right
foot
together to
build our knowledge and our application
almost like our epistemic and our
pragmatic value i think that'll be a
thread that's important to um
pull out what do you think about
that yeah that's a really helpful
connection
and i think this also speaks to that
usefulness of this
work beyond
modeling
directly is when when this idea of flow
is talked about in in these ways it's
kind of a bit vague right it's kind of
um and it still has this idea of things
flowing in a certain direction
um and are you in the flow and so i
think when we start to also have the
potentials for stochastic
processes and in a way the sense that
everything's flow um and you know how
does
what does low and high requirements mean
you know what does low and high
competencies preferences mean
and they kind of these are quite
bucket terms right and um essentially
they they are what they are because they
are workable
truth be told
but you know we can start to
look for something which can hold those
in a more unified way um
because i think that
um the way that we might feel in the
flow when we're in a zone
where we can both do things and we're
immersed in it
um
may may well be um
maybe what we're in all the time anyway
but it's just a different form of
um so that that also
changes you know the kind of
ramifications out there
great
point and we can actually um connect
that to this sort of view from the
outside and view from the inside which
we talk about a lot in active so it's
almost like there's the skier going down
the hill
and the view from the outside the
behavioral view is like
given the angle of the hill
they're optimally flowing that river is
physically optimally flowing down that
hill as you'd expect from the friction
and the potential energy and just the
physics of the setup
and then there's this
internal experience of flow so it's kind
of like
um maybe we are inflow all the time even
when we are getting for example
distracted or bored or frustrated
in what ways is that still flow
because if we think about flow well
flow's good you know um it's a state
where we're productive and happy and
things like that and then we're out of
flow that's what you'd hear in the
psychological literature
but let's just say that the river
we're flowing
and flooding
we don't say well we're done using flow
models because now it doesn't do what i
thought it was going to do
flow
is the whole space
so how do we think about this whole
psychological space
as being
particular regimes of flow
and flows the big topic that connects
stress
fear failing overwhelm concern
excitation etc
those are all flow states
maybe it's not the flow state that we
expect maybe not the one that we prefer
but a river can have flow states that we
don't expect or prefer either and so
it's like when we do abstract to the
physical systems we get a whole
quantitative toolkit
and we also get the ability to
maybe look beyond
phrasings that see flow as just
something to be obtained and rather flow
as the nature of
perhaps interior experience and then we
can talk about designing or perturbing
regimes of flow yeah go ahead
yeah that's a good point um
because from the out there's the outside
system like say seeing someone skiing
down a hill and you could say there's
different
ways of doing that and then as from the
inside
you've got essentially
a dynamic non-linear dynamical
organism
that's kind of trying to sort of thrive
and survive
and it's it's different there's no
getting away from that and um
the nature of that difference is
that's that's another question beyond
but
the the the interesting thing is on that
graph as well is often that graph only
that the flow is only shown on the top
right and not on the bottom left even
though it could be seen to flow down
and and um so something that's like a
quadrant and it's just the top right
which is seen as the flow
but what's also interesting is
it kind of depends again on these
multi-scale dynamics okay so
within certain scales of and temporal
scales
things start to fit our
our our
organism's preferred states
um some of which is kind of built into
our
morphology
so
you know if something becomes so easy
for instance
it's a lot easier if i'm trying to
protect a building just to stand in
front of the front door as a security
guard and nothing happens all day
but
and i may end up in some sort of flow
but there's a point at which
um
there's a desire for some stimulation
there's a desire for some change
and there's also maybe
changes that happen at the kind of
this sort of ties in with with um
saffron adam saffron's work about
you know windows of experience both in
real time and over time is
when is it kind of in the same sort of
time scales that we consciously function
in
um and when is something
beyond that you know so that could be
where stress and boredom or stress and
burnout can be both because the nature
of the activity
is is too rapid it's too disjointed for
the
our morphology
uh or it may be that we perceive it that
way because we have some
you know depressive depression or
anxiety that's also not enabling us to
engage in those ways
what's your thoughts
great let's take that point to one of
the formalisms of the paper so you just
mentioned how there's like multiple
time scales and there might be slower
time scales as well as faster ones which
might even be faster than our rate of
perception or modeling
which are one in the same if perception
is indeed a generative model
and this is very early in the paper in
section 2 from dynamics to densities so
they write the aim of this section is to
get from the specification of a random
dynamical system in terms of its
equations of motion
so the
for example differential equations that
define the time evolution of a dynamical
system
two the probability density over its
states in the long term future from any
initial conditions so going from
dynamical systems which takes us um into
the temporal realm
to the density realm and so there we
think about ocean water of different
physical densities
there's
a motion
to the densities because denser things
go down
and so that idea of denser things going
down or flow
from high to low density regions just
like in the atmosphere just like in the
ocean
that is going to be connected to
the behavior of
random dynamical systems
and to
information geometry so that's
a little bit of the next piece but
the two time scales are here
here's a classic flow model there's a
flow and then there's the fast
fluctuations so it's like there's the
river moving ahead at you know one
kilometer per hour
but each molecule
in that river is not always going at
exactly that speed rate
there's a fast fluctuation which might
average out to zero so in the bulk
aggregate or in the time aggregate
the flow
dominates the behavior of the river
but the fast fluctuations are also
occurring and they can often be
equivalent to a well-behaved i.e
gaussian error term
so this is where we see
the separation of time scales into sort
of the flow of the river and then the
vibration of the molecules
and those have two different
partitionings of
the system
the flow is well behaved because it is
just like a single number for the whole
river
in this simple example
and the fast fluctuations are well
behaved because they're
smaller if they were larger than the
flow they would become the flow itself
so they're smaller than the flow
and
they might be uncorrelated or have a
zero mean which allows us to do
gaussian statistics on them and then
this idea of
separation into slow and fast time
scales
is connected to density dynamics
through the focker planck equation yeah
stephen
yeah just
a little question on that so you the the
the the this time dynamic so flow
is both
at the time scale of interest i suppose
you could say
and potentially one which has a a net
kind of change in some sort of
directional kind of
gradient descent i suppose
and then
the fast fluctuations
it doesn't say random but it's probably
more stochastic um
but could also have flows going on so is
this um
is this is this um
you know how how much difference in in
the in the rate that they need to be to
be classed as
good low and fast good question
um so
the x with a dot is kind of like the
derivative of x it's the rate of change
in x it's the flow in x is going to be
decomposed
to these two terms
now we might be interested in a very
special solution to this equation
so again we have um x dot is kind of the
change in x which is being broken down
to these two dynamical
variables and then that's being
equivalent to the focker plank which is
more of a density framing so that's the
key
introductory step in the paper is just
to build this really strong equivalence
aka they're the same picture between
the dynamical specification and the
density specification
so if we could solve when the dynamics
were at a steady point that would be
equivalent to when the density would be
at a steady point
there might be some methods to help
solve it in one
phrasing or the other phrasing
it turns out that there's a
way to solve with a little bit more
feasibility when p of x equals zero so
that's when the flow
the density flow
given this is zero
and so that's what they're discussing
here
is um
basically
asking when does that equal zero
and that is a stationary point
so it's kind of like
doesn't mean it's just simply flat
in the reservoir but you know there's a
pump bringing water up to the reservoir
at 10 gallons per minute and then the
reservoir is dumping at 10 gallons per
minute
then that is going to be a point where
there's a stationarity
in the overall
densities of those two bodies of water
just like if it were two bodies of heat
and so we're solving for a special
place which is where the total flow rate
is zero
can i just ask a question from that
without going too deep but
so
in a way the the the flows the purp the
ability of having this
relationship to the flow
is it gives it gives you a sense i
suppose you could say it's like when the
graph the the gradient zero you know
that the top of a graph between two
types of
descent and it's
it's got like that that flat gradient
um it gives you a chance to
choose moments which could have a
particular
um set of properties without having to
calculate everything about it it's just
and
now when that happens what happens then
is it then that you then measure the
density and just keep measuring lots of
density points when you find the flow
points to be it
at a state of equilibrium or is there
something else so very good question
taking samples
and using that to say something about
the landscape is something we are going
to get to
welcome dean
so we will talk about how samples can be
empirically taken to say things
and do inference on the flow density
um
but you you made a good point which is
that like we want to figure out
something about a special point like
let's just say that we knew that we were
solving for a quadratic equation which
is going to come into play later so it
is going to look like a bowl
now it'd be awesome to know every single
point on the whole bowl
but it turns out we might only be
interested or mostly interested in
one point the bottom of the bowl
and for a quadratic function
the bottom of the bowl is the only time
that the derivative is zero
so we can have this big nasty quadratic
equation
and then
take the derivative of it the first
derivative
and then just ask
when does the first derivative
the slope of the curve equal zero
and we know that for a quadratic
equation there's only one point where
that happens and either it's like a bowl
or it's like an upside down bowl but
because we constrained the discussion to
a specific
family of equations which is going to be
important for variational inference
we can then
solve some very reduced
equations like the derivative which is
of a lower order of computational
complexity
and then just get the one point that we
actually wanted which is like the
location
of the bottom of the bowl
and then from the bottom of the bowl and
some of the coefficient estimates that
we have
we actually do get the whole bowl
so this is kind of like we're taking
some big family
of
equations
and then we're going to be looking for
special points like especially where the
flow is at equilibrium or stationarity
and then
fitting
a family of equations
with a form that we know we can compute
with
to
approximate
a flow that has a different underlying
dynamic and that is going to come into
play where
they show very early you can take a
lorenz attractor
which has some equations that govern its
motion so again those can be moved from
the equations of motion to the density
dynamics
and then you can reconstruct
an approximation of its dynamics
and your approximation to the dynamics
doesn't have to be even of the same form
as the generative process itself so it's
like you could fit a linear model
between height and weight
with some error
but that doesn't mean that there is a
linear model relating height and weight
it just means it's an approximation
heuristic with a form that's very easy
to solve
stephen and then welcome dean feel free
to add anything you'd like
so so in some ways this is a bit like
that particle wave challenge whereby
you know you have to use a particle to
find where something is in time and
space you have to just use a very
simplified
um understanding of the of the wave
to say okay at this point i have to i
can't
i can't have all that other information
but to have my location information
even if it's an informational location
so it's like that the flow
finding a point in the flow gives you a
way to identify
the
location maybe in the information space
and then the the foca plank
gives you a way to then
embellish that with another type of you
know put information back in
in a way
back into the into the
cake mix put a bit more
uh you know a bit more salt and a few
more uh chocolate uh
chocolate buttons in there and uh so you
can see what's going on um
okay that that's quite useful to think
about that would i be right in the sense
of like what those two equations are
doing one's
giving you
okay
some
chance to
to choose a
moment in information space or physical
space so at least you've got something
and then the other one's giving you a
way to then put some information which
you can then start to do some
variational processing on
i'll give a short thought and then dean
and blue feel free to say hello and um
just any overall thoughts and take it
wherever you want to go um
most
dynamical systems
have been framed classically
using these equations of motion so you
get like a matrix that describes the
differential equations
that describe the unfolding of the
lorenz attractor so it's framed as a
series of dynamical equations so this
early equivalence
allows us to bring some of the tools
of
fluid mechanics
and density dynamics and flow
to bear
on
these dynamical
systems
so there are some
ingredients or some
kitchen tools
that make
approximations to flow
very useful
for equations of motion that might be
intractable if you try to solve it on
just that domain
like figuring out
a chaotic system's underlying generative
process
it's basically
not possible
but potentially by approximating it
with a very specific type of
approximation families of functions that
we know have certain behaviors which
we're going to talk more about
using approximation families that are
well behaved
and
using some of the things
that have been developed from flow
decomposition like the helmholtz
decomposition
that doesn't exist for dynamical systems
so by making that equivalence between
dynamical systems and flowing systems
we can then use
flow
tools
to study
dynamical systems
as well as making it clear that we're
describing
the flow of our approximation
but it turns out that that does pretty
well at least in some of these examples
that they're going to present in the
paper
so
um dean and then blue
hi i'm dean i wasn't going to come on
today but
the conversation was stimulating enough
i figured i had to
jump in here and and
maybe add my two cents at some point
thanks
and blue
hi i'm blue i'm a research assistant in
new mexico and um
i yeah was into this paper because it uh
i don't know kind of
um piqued my interest in information
geometry and daniel i saw like in the
dot zero that you had mentioned that
course that's online i'm like gonna look
into that for sure
um
and you know i i'm curious about like a
lot of the leaps that were maybe made in
this paper between like
particles from particles to cells and
back to particles again and those kinds
of transitions get a little fuzzy for me
so i'm curious to see kind of where this
flows to
yep i think that was the information
geometry
course of john baez so that's like
again i haven't taken that but i know
that that's recommended and very cool
um
so we talked a little bit about
flow about that's kind of one of the
dreams that we could have a unified flow
model for heat and people information
behavior strategy etc
and one of the earliest moves that they
do in the paper
is just to really lock down this
connection between dynamical systems
systems through time and systems with
density so it's worth just repeating
that because that's
the second section of the paper and
that's going to be a lot of the build-up
another
term that comes into play
um is the leopardive exponent and
chaotic systems
so
if anyone has a thought of course just
raise your hand but one way that chaotic
is
quantified and formalized this doesn't
mean it's the only sense of the word
chaotic because sometimes people do use
it non-technically but the technical
definition of chaotic is referring to
the extent of the sensitivity of the
system to small changes for example in
initial conditions or in perturbations
and so there's
what's known as a leoponif exponent
which is something that can be
calculated from
the model of a dynamical system
and there are some dynamical systems
where
adjacent points
stay adjacent so it's like two pieces of
wood that are just put in a river that's
moving straight forward there's other
systems where adjacent points converge
or where adjacent points diverge and it
depends where you are in the system like
if you're at the bottom of the bowl
then
the either way you go it's like a stable
equilibrium you're going to get pushed
back in
but if the bowl were upside down then
either
point to the side of the top of the bowl
would push you and diverge so that's the
leopard exponent
and
there's
a lot of technical detail in exploring
chaotic systems from this perspective
so that's one
matrix
um term that comes into play is using
the leopardive exponents
especially the leading leopardive
exponents
to characterize some of the attributes
of a system
steven
i think it's good to mention that idea
of a system you know like two things
coming together and when they can meet
you know the system as well they can
converge or they diverge
but they could also when they bump into
each other there's also that
the the dynamics of the system
so as well as the of the system's
dynamics
merging the dynamics of the the change
it will stop changing once they meet
right so that there's also the extra
level of
dynamical change which you get with
these non-linear dynamical systems
which are actually working with the
dynamics of the change so it can sort of
reset itself it's not like with once
they've in a physical system they've
come together that's kind of it when
you're dealing with variations on change
it becomes much more generative
okay yes so sometimes these exquisite
sensitivities to tiny tiny differences
in initial conditions
they get swamped by random fluctuations
so
um
that's what's interesting about their
approach here is again they're
partitioning out the flow from the fast
fluctuations
and then they're describing how
when re when random fluctuations are
added in
then
the strange attractor is going to be
retraced by uh replaced by a pullback
attractor
and then the flow is the expected motion
so that's the movement of the river
of the flow
term
if this flow shows exponential
divergence of trajectories i.e
positively operative exponents we can
impute stochastic chaos
they
then
use
this approach to investigate one of the
classic
chaotic systems which has also been one
of the earliest chaotic systems of
lorenz
who
maybe there was some other livestream
where we did a little bit more on the
lorenz but it was a
meteorology question
lorenz and colleagues were studying the
weather
and how it changes and about some of the
sensitivity
of the dynamical models to tiny changes
like it seems like if it's you know 21.1
c
it seems like that should be very
similar in its behavior in the long run
to it being just 0.1 degree higher
and then as you got further away it's
like well then it'd be way more
different in the future if it's more
different today but then
it could actually turn out that a tiny
difference ends up sending your
equations haywire whereas a very
different initial condition
might actually like feed back and come
back to a similar attractor through time
so that's the kind of systems that they
were investigating in like the 1950s
and
there's been a lot of computer and
technical work since then but this is
still a total classic
and a beautiful strange attractor for
them to be working on as the first
example in their paper stephen
so what you're saying the the the
strange attractor is the kind of
complexity science idea of these
mathematical models where things get
caught in as you just described and
initial conditions
can can change the nature of what that
becomes within a certain range and
obviously outside that range it doesn't
it doesn't form so it's still kind of
off equilibrium
this pullback attractor
is a um
is is
a
almost a
a set of states which can be
moved towards
through
looking at the flows within
other types of chaotic attractors so it
is making a difference so it's
in some ways a strange attract sorry the
pullback attractor
would
or involve some sort of
inference or some sort of
some sort of driver to make it happen
it's not inherent to the to the
nature of the mathematics of that
particular
thing once you let it roll would i be
right in there
so the pull back attractor it's kind of
like let's just imagine the attractor is
like a post in the ground and there's a
bungee cord so if we were looking at
that quadratic bowl
it'd be like there's an attractor
at the bottom of the bowl and then
if all you saw was the
lateral movement of the particle so we
don't know anything about the height
necessarily or the shape of the graph
we just observe that when we push the
ball to the left
it gets pulled back as if it's being on
a bungee cord pulled left maybe it even
overshoots and it kind of dampens so
that's like a pullback attractor to a
point attractor
what's being shown here is an attractor
that is in higher dimensions so if you
had a two-dimensional pullback attractor
it'd be like the line y equals x and if
you get perturbed off the line you come
back down into the valley so that's like
where you start to see vector fields and
the flow of water into a river
and now
we're in a three-dimensional
attractor at least three
spatial dimensions
and so it's kind of like there's a race
car going around this butterfly track
and then it has the bungee cord so
you're getting pulled to this car
that's moving and then if you sample
your location at different times
you're being drawn to a pullback
attractor
which is the compromise between
the flow
as defined by
the equations of motions of the lorenz
attractor
and the fast stochastic fluctuations
dean and then
stephen
yeah just quickly i think this is why
sometimes using a
the the metaphor of building a bridge
is difficult because
uh not all at not all times is as
convenient as the lowest energy state in
a bowl
sometimes what we have to look at is the
fact that
at one end
call it point a
um
we're trying to figure out
what point b is and it isn't always the
lowest energy state i think here's an
example so if you ever if you've been to
hudson yards in new york
uh it's it's a fascinating translation
of a space over time and it and if you
were to ask the people who actually
constructed those
uh high trestles
at the at the point that they were built
if you did if you had asked them x
number of years later whether or not
that was going to be the lowest possible
energy state or attractor state i don't
think they could have predicted that
and so that's why i think it's difficult
at times when we
for the sake of convenience for effort
to expedite our sense of what's going to
happen next we use a connector metaphor
but in fact that's not exactly what
stochastic
possibility is about
so what we tend to do is collapse down
too quickly
down to the particulars of what purpose
a product can serve
and if we're going to build a bridge
from a product to a process which is
what i think
looking at stochastic
separation is about
we should maybe drop the idea of
a static connector and maybe look at the
back and forth and the actual dynamics
of those dynamic
situations which were now the tool
of active inference affords
cool interesting it just made me think
about like throwing a frisbee and it
catches on a roof
that's its lowest local energy state but
if you just thought about gravity maybe
you'd say well it's going to fall to the
ground so one particular trajectory
may not
realize
the ultimate lowest energy state yet
in a way it's in its own energy state
so stephen
yeah
sort of thinking again about
applications i think what dean mentions
is a good point is
there's an actual tendency to want to
have that kind of
bridge between two stable things
the thing with two stable things is it
is they're stable as we just mentioned
so therefore if you're trying to get
information about variations within them
particularly chaotic variations you're
not going to get much right so you you
kind of need
there's there's a need to be
off
out of equilibrium
to to give the conditions where things
can move in
potentially a strange attractor or
potentially other types of
you know solenoidal flows or something
there needs to be some way for flows to
happen
and then within that
which i think that might explain why
that last graph so if i'm if i'm right
in thinking that those four graphs that
you showed there
are kind of showing
that you've got this
strange
tract that you can sort of look at the
state space using
points
of where something has become moment
momentarily
zero in the the flow calculation gives
you a zero so you can therefore take a
point
and then the bottom right is basically
saying you can recapitulate that
as a global potential so you can sort of
by taking the changes
that happen in the second order you can
sort of recapitulate some kind of
understanding of the structure of the
information
is that right
there's
a lot there it
so i cannot reduce it to a binary but
yes it is showing
different aspects of how
strange attractors which are
found in these sort of exotic
deterministic chaos systems
like a perfectly clean double pendulum
and then how when we take the
approximation
we find a pullback attractor empirically
in
the approximation
so now we're describing a nicer still
stochastic but much nicer and more
approachable pull back attractor like
it's being pulled back to some
butterfly shape now we don't get these
like rings of jupiter situation from our
sampling because we're taking particular
samples and were fitting then
a flow what flow generated
those samples so we never see
rings of jupiter strange attractor we're
dealing with approximations of random
attractors
and then
we have at least two
tools slash
helpful techniques to apply
that are going to help us come to terms
with
that
approximation
so one of them is we're dealing with
flow
so we can talk about the helmholtz
decomposition so this was discussed a
lot in active 26
and as mentioned in the dot zero
stochastic chaos in markov blankets was
submitted like a few weeks after
26 was submitted bayesian mechanics
so
um
the helmholtz decomposition
describes this partitioning into the
irrotational kind of the gradient put
putting the ruler on the hill what is
the angle of the ruler if you're on the
top of the hill it's flat if you're on
the hill it's going to be at an angle so
separating that ruler on the hill
um to
the
hiking map the iso contour so let's make
the ruler flat
wherever it is whatever the slope is and
then let's just take that ruler and kind
of move it side to side as we go around
this hill
now if you're on the very top of the
hill
then the ruler is flat and there's no
iso contour
but if you're anywhere else on that
whole landscape other than a local
maxima
there's going to be some angle
to the ruler and some way to get around
the hilt
so that's the helmholtz decomposition so
that's one piece that we get to bring to
the puzzle and then
one piece that um would be interesting
to ask authors or someone with more
technical experience is
we've seen the helmholtz decomposition
before into the solenoidal and the
gradient components but then there's
this housekeeping term
um you know capital lambda
and that's described in an appendix and
it gets quite technical but it has to do
with
the
density landscape changing
as a function of flow
so it's not just like we're gonna have
one
mountain topography
and then we're gonna have rain falling
on that one mountain
there's gonna be some changes
as we flow around
so that it's more like you know you have
a jet of hot water into a cold water
you can't just take the
the mountain
of temperature
and then just ask what happens if we
pour hot water on top of that mountain
because the mountain is actually
changing the landscape is changing as a
function of the flow and some of that
gets incorporated into this housekeeping
term so one tool that we have is from
the flow toolkit is the helmholtz
decomposition
into
these different components that help us
reconstruct
a flow
that is a much better approximation
stephen
now you mentioned there that we've seen
solenoidal and gradient before with
helmholtz decomposition
when you say we've seen it before we
were saying we've seen it more recently
with the
solenoidal work
um or is the solenoid all been in there
with long
like this was drawn actually
oh yeah like we've discussed it in paper
number 26 and other papers like th this
is not a novel partitioning by the
authors
and it's very linked to other
discussions that we've had about
helmholtz decomposition in the context
of
distributional approximation
but previously was there it was more of
a focus on gradient descent
the focus was in your regime of
attention potentially
right it was
okay right going way back to early days
okay
okay so so in just without but in one in
the in that paper that was um
looking at solenoidal flow
it was it was
it was giving more weight to that wasn't
it would you say it was given more
weight was it using that in a different
explanatory way because there has been
this shift
around solenoidal flow
to give another way
beyond organicity to
explain how these dynamics can work
they're kind of co-instantiated because
they're partitionings from each other of
the same underlying model so which one
is emphasized more is totally a question
of situation and flourish
but
it also may be the case that
over the previous three years
there's more of an emphasis on
the importance of the iso contours in
complex problem solving as opposed to
just run and gun gradient descent
so
i agree with that so that's one tool we
have okay so we do the helmholtz
decomposition because again we're making
this deep equivalence between dynamical
systems and flow systems
so one tool we have from the flow world
is the helmholtz decomposition for
vector fields
now
they write
in section three one our objective is to
identify the functional form
so
could be used in the sense like what
function does it play or a functional is
like a function of a function
a functional form of the self
information or potential function that
describes the non-equilibrium steady
state density
okay so we go back to
in three
the fancy i
the fancy j
they write
the first dissipative part performs a
romanian gradient descent
on a manifold on the negative logarithm
of the steady-state density which can be
interpreted as the self-information
of any given state or as some potential
function so this is how surprise should
i be to be in this state so now let's go
back to our bowl
you shouldn't be surprised if you're at
the bottom
you should be surprised if you're at the
top there's high potential now if it
were gravity that were pulling us down
that would be potential energy
gravitational potential energy you have
higher gravitational potential energy
that can get dissipated
free energy can be dissipated
if you have greater
potential energy
so we want something that is just like
you could have the bowl
and the ball and know where is the ball
expected to be
and where is it going to roll down from
where is there potential that's high and
where is the potential low
and then
here in figure one they're going to plot
self-information
on the bottom left that's the y-axis
and then there's that is fluctuating
through time
as the system is cranked
it's kind of like if the
self-information we're staying we're
staying at a constant value it'd be like
if you're in that race car going around
the track
then you're always where you expect to
be because again the bowl it's like a
point attractor
and then the lorenz approximation is
going to be to
a dynamical approximation
so we want to find the function
of the non-equilibrium steady state
that's going to be describing how
surprised you should be
the potential function
for that system
so these are big questions like
how is the self information measured or
calculated
and then
what does it mean for the
self-information to be high or low
and how does the self-information for
different states that we might care
about
like homeostasis
how does the self-information in those
cases differ like is the
self-information higher or lower when
homeostatically you're in a good
attractor so dean and then stephen
so i don't know this but i would guess
that on some basic level the measure is
on its most absolute terms greater or
less than
to begin with
because i think that that that relative
difference
is something that anybody doesn't even
have to be aware of consciously
calculating they can just
you're kind of you can kind of tell
but i'm not really sure but i would
think
that as as we
as we go up in terms of the the
determination and the accuracy of the
measure we'll we would we could find
ourselves
getting more precise but on its most
basic level i would think it would from
a functional standpoint
that's where we would have to begin
yes and having um
being less surprised
about the state that one is in
entails having a richer and a more
accurate generative self model
so if you have a model that just totally
off base you're going to be recurrently
surprised
if you have a very nuanced
self model
your location and your circadian rhythm
then
different observations
will be less surprising
yeah i was just feeding back what you
were saying because you did a really
good explanation
but the in in your explanation that the
the key thing was i should be more
surprised or i should be less surprised
like you you yourself in doing the
explanation come back to that basic
difference
and so again as we get more precise i
think we can we can have more
sophisticated ways of being able to show
how we arrived there but at the
beginning even a two-year-old
can can somehow tell the difference
between more and less that's why they
dig in their heels right
so
it seems like on that basic level
before we get into some of the more
sophisticated stuff
we all can it where it says addresses
these questions for one simple case i
think on its simplest terms that's where
we can probably start
we can look there first if that's not
available i don't know that the other
math
matters i know it does but to the person
who can't see that first i'm not sure
where they go
this past weekend we were hanging out
with some larva with some children and
we were really struck by how there would
be some times where it seemed like you
just would tell them something totally
different like switch topic in the
middle of a sentence and they just went
along with it
and then other times where they needed
something really specific like they
wanted that piece of food and they want
it in this part of the plate and they
want to touch it this way and so it's
like they have a generative model
and there's certain parts
that they're surprised by or not and so
we're just like we want that piece of
food and i'm not too surprised at the
route it takes to my plate but if their
generative model entails a specific way
that that is going to get to their plate
they're going to be surprised by
anything other than that and if they
don't have a generative model of
topics in the world
then switching topics and talking about
this event and then that event it's just
like it's as if any other set of topics
were addressed so
great point about our intuitive
connection to surprising information how
that's related to our generative
modeling so blue and then stephen
so just um to go to your uh child model
like having you know had lots of kids
around for a lot of time
you know food is something particularly
that they like fixate on right
i mean i uh my younger stepdaughter is
like one of the easiest kids ever like
she's so chill and so laid back but like
i remember when she was about two years
old she would like freak out like one
time i cut i cut an apple for her like
sliced it up you know just to make it
like easy to eat and she like got so mad
because she wanted the whole apple the
whole thing um and she thought i was
only gonna giving her a part of it but i
think maybe food is i mean my point is
i'm rambling about the story but maybe
food is
one of these things that that is like so
baked in to our generative model because
otherwise the children have an attention
span of a gnat like you know you're in
the car and they start to argue and you
just say oh look at that pretty yellow
car right there and then they're done
they're over it like so so generally
like the you can surprise a child and
completely shift them but when it comes
to food it's like this weird and many
kids like not just you know aspen with
the apple but then there's also like
this food can't touch that food and like
they have a bigger piece of cake than me
and all this stuff so so it's food like
this fundamental like
baked in thing that that's like central
to survival and therefore it's like very
deeply ingrained in our generative model
maybe
nice agree stephen
yeah so the idea of children i'll keep
that analogy in there
if so we've got this these flows
happening and we we have
um
state spaces that get readings off so
the very first state space region i mean
unless you've got a prior somehow to go
on you don't really know what that means
and you get another one and another one
and so you get a series of state space
insights so to speak and then you'll
start to get a sense of whether
something's more or less than
i mean in the simplest term the average
right but you know we can then use
gradient descent and that to sort of
get get an understanding of that and
that with children that can be
interesting is
so yeah sometimes i just want to go with
everything and then and i notice also
like i get that with um my daughter
layla sometimes it's like you know
um
she'll she'll say like
i want something very specific or that
school there so and so went to that
school like now she knows that well i
know because that's what happened when i
was little meaning when she was a small
baby or
and it's all kind of made up
stories in some extent but it's kind of
like she's converging on she's got
enough state space information to say
okay
and and probably you've got that with
food right it's like there's there's
enough state space information to say
this and they can be prouders and i know
that and you didn't know that she said
to me you know i knew that you didn't
know that i knew that
this is quite cute but you've got that
okay so she's got enough
state space awareness
that's they're gonna converge down and
then there's other times like when you
want them to just
stay on the football pitch and not run
off to the swings uh they just go crazy
so
there's something about
you know sampling the space and saying
you've got enough information
and synchronization onto joint action
manifolds
is going to be one of the
prices of the paper
so blue as a response and then dean
so
you know super interesting about like
asking your daughter steven like you
know or the things she says that she
remembers from when she was a baby
something that's really fun to do with
kids and this also leads to like the
synchronization uh where i feel like
maybe where we're going but um
ask a kid when they can first talk like
when they can barely talk maybe like you
know two years old
um ask a kid where they were before they
were born um the answers are awesome or
like do you remember being in your
mommy's tummy like and like you know
i've heard ranges and ranges of answers
for from kids and it's really super
interesting so where is this like is it
some inherited prior is this like past
life regression or is it just like
they're falling into synchronization
they're making something up because
children have these like great
imaginations at that age but but where
does this come from like are they just
responding back to what they think you
want to hear this is like an absurd
question to ask a kid right like i mean
you can't really expect a reasonable
answer but ask because it's fun to find
out what what they think that they were
doing before they got here it's fun and
dean
first
yeah i i think it's interesting because
if you're going to go back to that
geometry
aspect of you know
can can two-year-olds think in the
abstract state yes they can
number one
and the other part i think i think where
we're sort of
we're all sort of synchronizing around
is that if it's less or more that can be
represented by the x and the y on a
graph
we've already shown that but if you want
to think whether it's in or out
you have to add that z
vector and that is the part that most
learning
doesn't necessarily explicate it's there
two-year-olds do it they know whether
they're in or out they know whether
they're getting the whole apple or a
slice
so
again i ask
are we are we attempting as people who
are trying to help the two-year-old
to build a bridge from point a to point
b
or should we be actually understanding
this as
building something that is a product
that is material
to something that is possible that's
what the stochastic field is until we
collapse it to that point b
right
and and the only way that that happens
is if we include in and out if we
include the zed
dimension to this so
again
if we
if we can't get in our own minds if we
can't get that correct
then we're actually going to get in the
way of developing pedagogy
it's i'm sorry to say that but it's
actually true so we we can think of
these little people as these wonderful
little right right brain the right brain
hasn't been brought down to
these these these equations at the
bottom of this page and yet they're
still able to function
their functional form is
self-information based on product to
process to be determined
okay so again i'm not saying this
because i've got it all picked up but
because i don't want
to have this active inference tool which
is a fantastic potential potentiator to
be collapsed to now
here's the here's the potential outcomes
that we can engineer a through zed
that that doesn't allow for a hudson
yards and yet there's a hudson yards so
if we're going to help people
let's not as you say daniel let's not
over reduce prematurely here in the
hopes of actually helping people when in
fact what that does is it says
as you fall out of the sky raindrop
you you shall depart this
this flow
uh in surrey british columbia or the
gulf of california or
at the at the mouth of the st lawrence
river we can't do that or we shouldn't
but we do and i can't understand why
the greatest thinkers do that well i can
because we like to talk
but but bottom line is we've got to
think rethink this that's what active
inference supports
totally
agreed and we can engineer the landscape
of flow you can add a dam so that the
water droplets do go one place or
another but
very interesting metaphor so stephen on
this and then we're gonna go to the next
tool that gets introduced
yeah i think
well i think i feel i know so there's a
question of it's an interesting question
as well when you say you've got a
two-year-old um
is where do they
get their knowing from so we have
abstraction in terms of thinking
abstraction
so we have well and and the sort of
ontological abstractions that we can
create around our knowledge structures
but you know they have access to two
years of state space
experiential sensations of which they
can then
make a story from
whichever way they so please as they can
so there's an interesting question um
that that what it means to know that's
abstract i.e or what's outside of
the sort of lived experience level and
it's sort of and there's that that other
way and
when when one thing i always find
interesting is i see a child is around
the age of two three
you see you really see a change in the
fingers that the whole morphology of the
body shifts
and i think one of the reasons that
maybe that memories aren't accessible
from before the age of three is
literally they were encoded in a
different body that's too too far
removed
to revisit the
the priors or the likelihoods from the
state spaces that have been laid down
um so it may be partly
a natural way that we sort of forget
but we don't necessarily forget thoughts
that we had cognitively we just forget
the um the embodied stuff because we're
gonna we're gonna lay down some new
stuff unless you have a trauma in which
case that can lock in certain states
blue any comments on that
of course so you know
it's interesting um
the the
encoding in a different body i mean
we're doing that every seven years right
um like we've full cell turnover but you
know there's there's this process of
synaptic pruning that happens
um so as like we're babies you know we
grow bazillions of neurons and then
synaptic pruning happens like around the
age of two or three where a lot of those
neurons die back and then the ones that
stay uh exist and continue to to build
stronger and build better but everyone
is so completely different in terms of
like their ability to remember things
from when they were baby and not always
related to trauma like i have no
conscious memory stream until like i was
10 which is super late and like there's
no i mean maybe i might do some like
hypnosis and reveal some kind of trauma
like at some point in my life but
i mean for me to not have any like i
remember like some flashes of some stuff
i remember the photograph he showed me
the picture oh yeah i remember that do i
remember it no i probably remember the
picture of it right like so there's this
whole other level of thing but the idea
of being encoded in a different body
is super interesting because of course
my body's different now also but from
when i was 10. right but i mean also
like you know when you're 90 your body's
different from when you're 50. so what
stays what goes
how is it chosen is it this embodied
aspect of it or is it just like you know
we lock into the things that we think
are important for our model and if it
doesn't if it's not relevant for our
model maybe we just let it go
dean
i just want to say this real quick
because i know you want to move move
forward daniel but everything that we
describe here in order to get to a
concept of between
whether it's between
us today and us
seven years plus a day before that
between or any other between that we
want to describe
at some fundamental level we have to be
able to discriminate between more and
less
and what's in
and what's out
if we can do those things
we in any situation can describe between
now
once we can describe between we can see
a difference between what a product is
the bottom of this slide and a process
something that that equation
can do
if we can get if we can get that clear
then stochastic
chaos
is a between thing
that we can then manipulate to a certain
outcome or we can leave open
to possibility if we can get that
just that
we we will have conquered more than most
people have conquered in their lifetime
because
they use the word between but i don't
think they necessarily understand
what makes that up
and i think that's what we
i that's what i would like to be able to
share with others and co-learn
with others as opposed to
excuse me building another
set of specific outcomes that we can
measure and say this was you
one month ago
you a and this is you now seven years
plus a day
and now we're going to now we're going
to decide whether or not you're closer
to some thing that i've arbitrarily
selected as the thing that makes you
have learned something
if we can get there could you imagine
how amazing that would be that's just
that one thing sorry i get really
passionate about this but holy crap i'm
actually talking to people who can
actually hear that and go oh
that's interesting instead of just
dismissing it out of hand and going we
don't need to learn that because we
already know what between means
between is geometric
so for sure information geometry will
come into play and then the idea of
taking
vast
situations
and through time with uncertainty and
then calculating more or less
kafka expected free energy
that could be an extremely helpful
approach so blew anything on this or
we'll continue
yeah so what's the next tool are we
going right into the markup blanket
because man when we talk about between
oh yeah i just want to get to the markup
like it um
when we talk about between i think that
having that idea of the markov blanket
anyway i'll add it at that time so so go
on carry on absolutely the markov
blanket is um even understood by the
non-technical as a betweenness
but is it the betweenness that is your
epithelium mechanically or what kind of
betweenness are we actually talking
about
we need the tools
let's go to the next tool
so
however this is the quote in general we
cannot discount the correction term that
arises when flow operators are a
function of states
so if it were just mount everest we
could just do the solenoid and the
gradient decomposition and then figure
out how to combine iso contours with
gradient climbing and we would get to
the top however
swept under the rug by the housekeeping
term
is this
change in the underlying
mountain landscape
indeed it is this state dependency that
underwrites stochastic chaos so a way to
think about that as like the double
pendulum
the chaoticness of that system arises
from the exact angle that the double
pendulums are in you can't just say
there's a mount everest and it's the
bottom it's like okay not very helpful
for me predicting these wacky waving
shapes it's doing
this presents us with a more difficult
problem
the problem can be finessed
by using polynomial expansions
of the flow operator and the potential
as follows for n states so it could be 1
2 3 4 n dimensions
up to polynomial order m
so a linear approximation has a
polynomial order of one a quadratic
approximation has a it has a polynomial
order of two and so on so it's like
fitting higher and higher order terms so
the big idea is that we're going to use
polynomial expansions
to approximate complex underlying flow
functionals
polynomial expansions do
many things but most importantly they
restrict or scaffold our model selection
approach to a very specific form
and function and size and tractable
computation so
individuals might be familiar with a
taylor series which is where you take a
given point and you say well what is
this function at that point like the
sine of zero is zero and then you say
what's the first derivative that's this
red line and then you say what's the
second derivative okay it's starting to
curve a little down okay what's the
third derivative and so on and you can
use the taylor series to approximate
that function
further and further out from your
entry point that you're calculating the
first second third fourth fifth
derivative on etc
and then
this is a static
approximation so this is something that
might be learned in high school or
college level maths
a topic that's very related but not
always discussed is the volterra series
and so
the volterra series is a model for
non-linear behavior similar to the
taylor series it differs from the taylor
series in its ability to capture memory
effects the taylor series can be used um
for approximating the response of a
nonlinear system to a given input if the
output of the system strictly depends on
the input at the given time
and this
is developed quite extensively the
volterra in
spm textbook by fristen at all so again
many of the seeds and roots of what
we're talking about today
check the spm
textbook and documentation
because that's where a huge amount of
this
competency in these authors arose from
and how they represented it almost 15
years ago
so
what happens when we do this polynomial
expansion of the functional fort well
first off we moved the problem that we
were solving from static mountains only
to
trampolines that are moving as we're
walking
that's what brings
state-dependent changes into the mix and
action as well
and it moves us from again a static
landscape that we can just calculate
where the rulers are flat on
and then just figure out the best way to
get there well you can't just lay a flat
ruler if they're state dependent changes
because where the ruler's flat at t zero
is not where the ruler is flat literally
the next moment dean
yeah i think this is excellent daniel
because what this now says is
now we can explain why there are
impressions
why there's some residue left over why
the in and out aspect of this not just
the bump
but the in and out going through that
bump
also has to be
accommodated or export at least
acknowledged as part of everything that
we're looking at here the whole thing
so yes
that's a great explanation thank you
and the learning landscape isn't just
the mountains the interaction landscape
is more like it's like the coupled
systems we'll get to soon but it's even
one person learning landscape
is like
being in trampoline world sometimes
so
that brings us into this
space with many important topics that
are discussed
in an earlier
and different way by the spm textbook
now how good
is or could be this polynomial expansion
they write inspection of the lorenz
system suggests that a second order
polynomial approximation is sufficient
given the flow is second order in the
states
so
we're fitting an approximation that has
two terms so it's like a quadratic
so that's why we talked so much about
the bowl
because the approximation that we're
fitting
is bowl-like
which allows optimization techniques
that are simple like convex optimization
those are easy roll the ball to the
bottom of the hill by minimizing the
potential function
which potential function the free energy
potential function the free energy
functional
whereas if it was a rugged optimization
landscape
you get the whole headache of how do you
know when to stop and what if there's
just a whole neighborhood you didn't
even go to so
it seems like
potentially a second order approximation
is sufficient
then they use this word onsots which is
nice it's an assumption about the form
of an unknown function
made in order to facilitate solution of
an equation or other problem
so now we're going to go with this idea
that if we can
have a second order approximation to the
lorenz we're going to be doing good
enough let's work with that and see if
that turns out to be the case
so it turns out
if this thing that's so hard to model
the self-information the surprise
the potential function is modeled by a
second order polynomial
then the non-equilibrium steady state is
approximately gaussian
this is known as the laplace
approximation in statistics which is
also in spm very helpfully
here we generalize the notion of laplace
approximation to cover not just the
quadratic form of the log density but
also the solenoidal flow that
underwrites non-equilibrium dynamics
so the laplace approximation in
classical statistics
is like we're going to take the density
distribution of
what we're trying to estimate
and we're going to find the peak
the maximum point and then we're going
to fit a gaussian over that peak
and so if there's like a big shoulder
and then a tiny shoulder you're just not
going to get that tiny shoulder right
but that's a very rich distribution if
it really has that structure in the real
world
what you're going to get for that
distribution is
a gaussian centered around the big peak
so for some distributions you're going
to be way off there are things
that are hard to estimate
and there's things that don't work well
with the laplace approximation it's not
a solution it's an approximation however
if we're interested in the mean and the
variance around potentially the bulk of
a distribution
then
solving the
parameters for the laplace approximation
is as easy as fitting a quadratic
which is to say
the ball sliding to the bottom of the
bowl and once you go beyond second order
approximation
you have a third order quadratic
there's a whole
another world because then the ball
could get caught in that first little
elbow or it could fall off the other
side
so higher order approximations
they take more computational resources
and while they might have increased
accuracy
they can often be less tractable to
actually solve so this is
at least
in my reading a pretty fundamental
contribution to
the statistics of complex systems
because they've taken the notion of
laplace approximation
not just towards estimating the mean and
the variance of some distribution out
there
but
to
the solenoidal component of flow post
helmholtz decomposition related to
non-equilibrium dynamics
stephen so
like at up to this point we actually
don't need markov blankets yet it's
giving this we haven't used the word so
how's not going to play has not come to
play yet at all
exactly exactly
so
it's telling so you've told the story
of what needs to be in place for
there to be the the kind of
state spaces
and then the nature of these state
spaces being so changeable
and non-linear
and then
there's this on top of that then there's
a way to
attractively work within that which is
the la pass approximation in statistics
which gives you
does it always give one gay gaussian on
any landscape or is there multiple or is
it just one per landscape is that yes
per
dimension per state the laplace returns
one and only one mean and variance
it's like fitting a gaussian
distribution to the log density
so it does only give one which is why i
gave the example of the two hump it's
going to pick one
and go there and all right so yeah let's
look at figure two and so
how interesting though that
the papers mark off blankets and still
cast the chaos
but we're not even at the marco blanket
but the way that it gets led into
is very
um
improved and different than what we've
seen before
instead of assume a partition
dot dot dot dot
we're starting way back so now
here on the left
is the flow of the lorenz system
using the helmholtz decomposition
so here are the three components of the
flow as they've described it the blue is
the gradient
the orange is the solenoidal flow and
then the gold is the correction
housekeeping term
right
this uses the same format but for a
laplacian system based upon the lorenz
in the upper panel
so we're going to be fitting
a laplace like approximation to
each of the states
each of the dimensions of this lorenz
strange attractor
the key difference is that the
dissipative part of the flow operator
and the hessian are positive definite so
just really quick matrix vocabulary the
jacobian matrix
is the matrix of the first partial
derivatives so in the x y and z
dimensions or however many there are
what is the angle of the ruler that's
the first partial derivative
the hessian
is the second order partial derivatives
so it's describing the local curvature
so if someone said my ruler's flat and
it's curving down you're on the top of a
hill if your ruler's flat and it's
curving up you're at the bottom of a
hill
and so on so that's how the zeroth the
value of the function the first
derivative and the second curvature are
used like
in calculus
so
the hessian is positive definite which
means the gradient flows converge to the
maximum of the non-equilibrium
steady-state density this is reflected
by the blue arrows that point to the
center of the state space
so in the lorenz world
you're getting race card around the flow
is taking you all over the place yet
by making the laplacian approximation
all of a sudden the flow
the attractive part that's dominating
the movement within that space it's
actually convergent
so that's not to say the lorenz system
converges to a stable point
it's to say our approximation parameters
converge towards potentially a more
tractable and simple attractor
in the abstract approximation space
and we'll see how well of an
approximation that indeed is but that's
the key difference is here the blue
arrows are taking you on a wild ride
as the gradient takes you around the
lorenz flow here we're doing a flow
composition on our approximation which
we constructed to be of a certain type
and it turns out to have properties
in its attractor that are very different
than the loretz
dean and then stephen
uh unmute dean and then yes
here's a question for everybody here if
if we're talking about
a
process could we be looking at those
over time seeing those arrows in both
the lorenz and the
place decomposition
thickening or expanding or
like having water added to them is has
anybody contemplated whether in fact
that is what is happening over time
so the fit is actually from a within
that the space is getting filled up by
these arrows growing
in terms of their circumference
very interesting question
the length of the arrow usually
describes the amplitude like the speed
of the flow in that moment i do not know
if i've seen a visualization where the
tree rings the arrows represent thicker
or thinner vectors but great question
and if anybody with more experience in
vector math
has a thought that could be very
interesting to know okay
stephen and then blue
and just to clarify that i've got this
right but in each of those um
points where you've got the blue arrow
and the solenoidal flows so each one
would be
solved so to speak for that point as a
as a um
you know a gaussian
approximation and then by this is like
an assemblage of multiple
results of a gaussian approximation and
it's sort of mapping them out so to
speak and so you know this this idea of
multiple
pieces of information and nestedness is
it sort of comes into play with this
yeah there's some landscape
and we go out there with our ruler our
jacobian and our curvature ruler our
hessian and then we're going to make
just transects on the hill and we're
going to just sample a bunch of points
and add a bunch of points you know one
comma one one comma two
we're going to use the ruler and the
curvature
and we're going to look at at that point
where the field is
pointing
and then
if you've sampled at um in inadequate
resolution you're not going to see your
coherent
vector field
so you need to sample at a resolution
that allows the vector field to be kind
of obvious
so blue
so i just want to point out for people
who might not know that
you need to have a positive definite
hessian
to calculate a covariance matrix like in
statistical analyses that i've done this
is like one critical
point and if you don't have an
invertible hessian then you have to
recalculate your model because
all of your factors are too entangled to
find out how they are covaried together
or separately so i just wanted to for
anybody who doesn't have the background
in in matrix math um
point that out
yes thanks dean
so blue help me does that mean literally
that you can't thin
one of those
arrows
you can't you can't let certain things
be purged from your state space
because that's like i really don't know
i'm not questioning i'm asking a
question from a statistical standpoint
and then being able to translate that to
the physical
reality
so i don't translate to physical reality
well my brain just like doesn't work
that way
but but what has to happen is what that
really means is you can't establish
conditional independence
without having some idea of the
covariance and so if you can't calculate
the covariance you can't discover this
conditional independence which is where
we're building up to
in
in specifying the markov blanket so i
just want that's that's why i wanted to
just point that out because you have to
have that
ability to find that that covariance
okay let's go to where the covariance
comes into play and then stephen so
we're gonna address
how well does this approximation work
because i mean we're fitting a few
quadratics
to like the og complex system is that
really going to work
what's being shown in figure three
is
um on the very top so this is the left
one is second versus third first versus
third and first versus second so these
are like three projections on a cube so
we're looking on a flat screen or piece
of paper about a three-dimensional
state space
and the red dots are the sampled
trajectory
in that cube so it's like there's a
firefly moving around in the cube and
we're looking at it this way and so
we're projecting it onto that
screen
and then in the background
we see this very nice
unimodal
gaussian
attractor
so the lighter part is like the
attractor part and then the darker part
is
higher potential function
more surprising less likely
so that is the lorenz trajectory
being played out
in our
laplace-like approximation cube
and so it can be shown that the flow of
the laplace approximation
it it has some of that kind of butterfly
race car dynamics
it's probably doing a lot better than
just sticking a linear equation through
it but it's not perfectly recapitulating
the underlying lorenz system so how good
is the approximation
well
one thing that this approximation is
going to live or die by is whether it
can characterize
the lorenz system as chaotic or not
because if it turns out that the way
we're going to deal with chaos systems
with a positively open of exponent is
fit a non-chaotic model oh i made an
oscillator pendulum to describe
homeostasis
okay so you made a simple model great
but what's really interesting is if our
approximation
could also reflect chaos yet handle it
tractably so what they do in formalism
is they show that the estimated lyopniv
dimension
for the approximation
is
2.48 and they use some um numerical
approximation techniques here like by
sampling a grid
kind of that transect sampling idea but
for the leopardive exponent at those
points rather than say just the gradient
and that favors
um or that um compares very favorably
2.48 2.43
importantly they're both like similar
and way over one
with the actual analytical
leopardive dimension
so
the approximation is actually
highlighting the chaotic nature and
almost quantitatively the extent of the
chaos because there's more and less
chaotic systems
and so
for our purposes the laplace
approximation is easier to handle than
the lorenz system because the functional
forms of the flow and potential are
immediately at hand
that's the whole point we used an
approximation family of equations that's
going to be like having a ball rolling
down to the bottom of a bowl rather than
being swept up in turbulent flow
figure four is where we get to the
covariance that blue mentioned
okay so we're going to have
three states those are the x y and z
states or dimensions of the lorenz
system
and now
um we can look at the log of so the log
is just sort of a
transformation to help highlight some of
the differences between zero and one
especially
we can see the log of the jacobian which
is that first partial derivative the log
of the hessian which is the second
partial derivative and then the log of
the covariance
in the middle which is like what blue
was referencing so here
the first and the second
states dimensions
have very high correlations
neither of them are correlated with the
third so the on diagonals are states
being correlated with themself the first
and the second dimensions have high
correlation well what does that look
like when we use that cube shining light
so on the bottom left here
we can see like the first and the second
have a like an oblong relationship
that scatter plot has
a significant regression through it
there's a correlation coefficient
there's mutual information there
there's non-sphericity
whereas the other ones that are
uncorrelated relationships have what
looks to be more of a spherical
correlation like if you sample variable
a and b and it's just a circle
there's no mutual information
and so interestingly
the covariance
matrix
looks a lot like the hessian matrix
so
that is providing evidence
that if what we care about is the
covariance amongst the states
we're getting a very similar structure
when we use
the second order polynomial
approximation
to those states
and it turns out that it does
pretty well
if you want to for example estimate
the first state given the second so
what if we could only measure two
dimensions well we wouldn't want to pick
one and two because they're basically
correlated in their measurements
we would want to pick two and three and
then do a really good job at predicting
one given two
which is to say that the informational
dimension of this system is
between two and three
it's two and a half basically
so those are some of the connections
between covariance amongst different
dimensions
and
polynomial expansions
to
dynamical systems based upon flow
approximation
and then just to summarize here then we
can have any questions and then in the
last 20 minutes we'll look towards the
markov blanket we still haven't even
gotten to the markov blanket yet
so just this is the um the foothills of
mount markov
and
they write it's important not to compl
conflate
it's important not to conflate the
simplicity of a non-equilibrium steady
state density
that's this one
with the complexity of the underlying
density dynamics
the map is not the territory you just
cannot say it enough simple
approximations are not claims about
system simplicity
in other words when prepared or observed
in initial estate the probability
density can evolve in a complex and
itinerant fashion on various sub
manifolds of the pullback tractor and
they're going to use information length
to talk about that but the important
thing to know is just that our
approximation has attributes that
resonate with the original underlying
systems dynamics as well as attributes
that we specifically know are different
or they might be different or not but no
matter what they're not claims about the
underlying system so that's not a pipe
stephen
yeah i think this also speaks to
this idea of triangulation or multi
modality
is like say this this isn't directly
speaking to what's out there or what the
system or
or what you could say what whatever the
things are that have been
inferred
so there needs to be or that the more
approximations that can be triangulated
as i say which is kind of what happens
in qualitative research qualitative
research is all about the triangulation
of research not about the exact measures
and accuracy within research
then you can
get a better
grip
potentially on what might be out there
if that makes sense so like you say with
that pipe you kind of
you know if i could if i could go in and
you know i've only got i've only got one
aspect of that reality so i can only
resolve it to a certain degree um and it
is what it is and then i i'd have to see
i i don't know how big that is as a
painting how you know until i see it in
a gallery etc etc right so
um
yeah i think that that this this
the need to find the way to get an
approximate weigh-in
means that you need to have many
approximate ways in to
start to make
a higher level confidence in what you're
thinking
thanks stephen dean
yeah daddy can you go back slide 48 for
a second yes
so this is the fascinating thing about
contrast and proportion
because you've got nine
squares up in the upper right there with
the jacobian and the
and the covariance and the hessian
trying to translate that and that then i
understand this is this is the big uh
this is the sort of the the
grail of translation to translate that
and the
contrast and the proportion that you see
there to fresh eyes to new eyes they
might look at that middle one
with it with a completely different
sense of what that pattern is describing
for us than the than the two outside
slices of bread
to us because we're a little bit more
familiar with it the contrast in the
proportion you can actually see where
they has cn matters from a statistical
standpoint but drop that into a context
now where you've got mountains and
rivers and lakes and forests and streams
and how do we take that information
there which is which is really quite
clear to people who are familiar with it
and translate it to the context the
situation in which we find ourselves and
are now trying trying processing to a
converged sense of context what does
this
what does this envelope tell us right
we're inside of this cube now how do we
get outside of it use this tool
to so we to re-enter
the context and have a a
an upon sense of what covariation
means
this is this is the grail if we can set
up our learning experience
as a situated one where we take this
tool in
but don't confuse the tool as you say
don't confuse the math
with with the field
that's that's again
it's it's fantastic if you can get a
whole bunch of people seeing
what what's the big picture here what's
the tool
what's the contrast in proportion with a
tool
and then what is the context what's all
of this fractalized stuff out there in
different colors
and different shapes and different sizes
how do those how do we put those two
things together into some sort of
coherent narrative
great point
so in the last
10 to 13 minutes
we're going to finally converge to
the m word
markov blanket
um and then next week it would be
awesome to speak with any of the authors
or anyone else who would like to share
their perspective
or
we'll continue because like
we're basically halfway through and we
haven't gotten to the core piece of the
markov blanket so we're gonna just look
where we're going
in the last little bit of dot one and
then in dot two we're gonna like you
know land on that markov trampoline and
then see where we go
okay
in section four
they're going to repeat the analyses of
the previous section
approximating two lorenz systems coupled
to each other through their respective
first states
this induces a richer conditional
independent structure from which one can
identify internal and external states
that are independent when conditioned
upon blanket states so
this is
the more classical markov blanket
definition which is blanket states are
those
that conditioned upon them make internal
and external states conditionally
independent so that's a definition that
we've seen before and the internal
external and blanket states they all are
co-instantiated it doesn't make sense to
talk about one without the other
and
we've mentioned that before so in
um
figure seven it's a lot like figure
three
where we were looking at those three
projections of the cube of one lorenz
system well now we're looking at two and
it's pretty clear from looking at their
trajectories
as well as just from their movement in
the state space like these are pretty
synchronized so
some
coupling has been instantiated
no different than if you had like two
engines and then you connect them with a
heat transfer device they're gonna have
coupled temperature fluctuations except
now it's like more statistical
figure eight
is a lot like figure four so in figure
four we had this three by three
matrix describing the first partial
derivatives second partial derivatives
or the covariances
of states one two and three and the on
diagonals were staged with themselves
and the off diagonals were states with
other states
now
we're going to have
three plus three states
two sets of three two coupled lorett's
one two and three is the first lorenz
and then four five six are the three
states of the second lorenz
you see that in the jacobian there's
high correlation
within
each lorenz system and then there's that
one and four
where there's a strong value that's the
coupling like that is the cell that
represents the coupling between the
first upper quadrant and then the lower
right quadrant
and that induces some extremely
interesting covariance structures
that is what we want to investigate it
turns out that by looking at the hessian
of this system
some partitions fall out
those partitions
can be numerically
analyzed to show that
[Music]
basically there's
partial correlations
that approximate the hessian of the
lorenz systems that are coupled
so
we can use
the hessian which we already established
the second order polynomial expansion is
like basically adequate
we can use the hessian of our
approximation not of the system not the
system has a hessian our model of the
hessian
approximation
very well
aligns with the partial correlation
and so that's demonstrated
by showing that two states that
shouldn't have correlation third and
sixth and fourth and fifth so like here
three and six are not correlated
we can show that even if they start very
correlated like they just happen to
start at a similar value
the dynamics of the system actually move
them towards having a zero or even a
slightly negative partial correlation so
our
hessian approximation
is giving us deep insight into the
partial correlations
and then i
think a great place to sort of um
[Music]
posit
is with this connection of the graphical
bayesian network that we've looked at
before
with that same partitioning into four
states internal external and blanket
states now fristen and others
then partitioned the markov slash pearl
blanket states
which are of one kind
into these two kinds of blanket states
incoming sensory states and outgoing
action states that's what links us with
perception cognition action and control
theory and
planning as inference so this is an
image we've seen before
and here are those six states
so one two and three that's lorenz
system one one then four five six is
lorenz system two
and one and four is the only cross
coupling that we're putting into the
model that's this cell right here so
we're cross coupling one and four you
know you have two neurons
they have two neurons and then there's a
little tin can between the two of you
and that's inducing
a global structure to all six nodes so
you don't need to have every neuron
wired to every neuron
there's sparsity in this connection
structure
and
technical details aside
that is going to relate to the
partitioning which we're going to be
deriving
a partitioning
on the hessian
which is a second order polynomial
expansion
of our
model
so
i think um
that is um a great place to
go for today
and uh just then just to close and we
can have last thoughts or what we want
to talk about next week just to
reiterate there's no claim either the
original lorenz system or
coupled lorenz system possesses a markov
blanket so the territory doesn't have a
markov blanket our coupling doesn't even
have a markov blanket
the claim here is that there exists a
laplace approximation to these kinds of
systems
that in a virtue of the zero elements of
the hessian feature markov blankets
so not has a markup like it is wants to
be did have
those are
speculative interpretations that maybe
future larva will discover to be the
case or not
but what this paper actually claims is
very far from that
blue and then stephen
okay so here we're going to stop just
since we're getting good just as it's
getting really good okay um it's the
cliffhanger for next week i just wanted
to leave off with where this figure is
in the paper like right under that
figure it says the names active and
sensory or blanket states inherit from
the literature where these states are
often associated with biotic systems
that act on and sense their external
mulu
so
i'm like why are they imputing sensory
states onto particles like this is where
the great leap in the paper kind of
happens for me and i'm like okay now my
particle
is sensing
which is like to me okay like i'm
actually okay with that like you guys
know you've seen me like
i'm pretty good with pan psychism at all
at overall and um it doesn't really make
a big deal
big difference for me um i'm still very
interested but
it's something that a lot of people i
think are going to get maybe uh tripped
up by so i would like to hash that out
and to say well there's absolutely no
claim that real systems have a markov
blanket
you know like the skin
it's like
are we going to be talking about real
systems and how it maps onto physical
components of the real world and the
mechanisms of sensory transduction
or is this about the hessian
approximation
to the laplace
so
sometimes very close to each other in
the text
so that can make it a little bit
ambiguous stephen
yeah
um very very cool yeah blue blue makes a
good point
i suppose what i'm sensing here here and
correct me if i'm wrong is that this is
showing a way to show that patterns can
be existing
within the covariance of um
attractor states or attractors
just in themselves it could just be a
blob of stuff right in amongst blobs of
things and stuff and particles and then
it also shows that
there can be
the ability for
those
dynamics
to partition out
so it's
kind of
gives a bit of two ways it gives the
partition outpieced
and then it also gives
a way to have a blob
this is a very technical term a blob of
very
useful stochastic chaotic states which
don't need to be themselves
blanketed
but could be what becomes just sort of
sensory states for instance
but could be a reservoir
within a bigger reservoir and would that
be
a correct
sort of assumption if we truly had no
difference between our approximation
and our incoming observations like we
had a perfect model
then
maybe there'd be a valid claim that the
map was the territory and for systems
that we define in software it actually
can be that way
but for any real system this
approximation there's always going to be
a delta between the incoming
observations and our approximation and
so the claim here is that it's the
hessian the second level polynomial
expansion of our approximation that has
some very nice mathematical properties
not that the system has that or any
specific properties
dean
yeah i would just
speak to the idea that the skin is a is
a great example because
you can look at it only as a product as
a limit
or you can look at skin as a process i
mean we know that
all the processing that's going on there
so
again
do we do we do we collapse it down to
one type of function as a product as a
limit
or do we see it actually as a process as
well as as a something that's dynamical
something that's constantly changing and
then that opens up the idea of what
between means now i don't know if it
takes it down to the particle level
seems like it does at those at those
blank scales but i'm not really worried
about that so much as i'm i'm
interested in the idea
of what
betweenness is
because i don't know that skin
automatically
is a partition sometimes it's a process
as well so if we keep that open that'd
be something interesting to take up next
week
great yeah i think if anyone else has
any
comments like what a fun
paper and dot one we
hit a lot of the warm-up
stretching and preliminary topics
and contextualization that brought us
like right to the vista
of mount markov with further clouds
behind even that
but we're where we know that we can step
into the dot 2
with a backpack that's prepared and then
these are really interesting and clearly
either unresolved and or uncommunicated
and or unapplied questions in
literature in the state of the art which
is what is the relationship between
these formalisms and specific
nouns and verbs
in the world the kinds of things that
we're semantically engaging with and if
it turns out that the semantics of a
markov blanket are not like the
semantics
of any other thing
or they're importantly different from
the semantics of
what we currently feel familiar with
great
or it would be interesting if they do
map or overlap or encompass or nest
within some other semantics that already
exist but that's the question
so um
we can just look at our final
closing questions and if anyone has a
thought otherwise 32.2
next week on november 16th
and
we hope to hear from you if you would
like to
join the discussion live just get in
touch with us or contact us at
activeinference gmail.com
or just show up and
ask questions or make comments in the
live chat
but
interesting stuff
we were
a little trepidatious with such a
complex paper
but
i think bringing simplicity
and simple rules underlying complex
behavior and how can our approximations
be tractable even when the world is just
infinitely surprising
those are some of the fundamental
questions that this paper and active
inference address so blue steven and
dean
great work
and we will see everybody
next week
bye